[Music]
if you are going to pout rogue don't
expect much the second time around have
you started planning the wedding I have
tonight yeah I'm so busy you know there
I'll get oh I will
I will at some point big will everybody
be involved I'm old to have a big
wedding and a big old white dress and
all that like I gotta be like I got a
dial it back here a lady is never too
old to have a white dress and a big ring
honey that's a good thing did I hear you
saying you and Carl are gonna have all
your animals in the wedding yes we are
okay so when is this happening because
we've all been like on pins and needles
waiting for this day there's no info
when it's happening but there will be
let's put it this way there will be no
animals left behind every animal we have
will be part of it it's gonna be very
special very emotional
[Music]
so are we having an LA wedding are we
going destination I don't know I have no
idea yeah I was thinking about Hawaii
Chiba dress no I know I want like lace
and long sleeves Megan's been shedding
for the wedding
down 20 plus pounds her healthy habits
include no alcohol no smoking just water
and workouts with fiance daryl samara he
saved my life and everything away and he
taught me how to eat really healthy and
we work out together we do everything
together sometimes we work out we cook
together and we're just like cute it's
gross like everyone hates us you know
any of that couple secrets on how
bride-to-be kaley cuoco got this bod she
did soda and started getting cupping
other tips I sometimes do meatless
Mondays I try to go all day without
having any meat on Mondays I was a
spinning fanatic and I think I needed to
shock my body yoga did it for me Bikram
heated heated hot yoga I like leaving
feeling like drenched with sweat a Felix
I feel five pounds lighter when it's
recently posted this shirtless shot of
fiancé Brad Falchuk she calls him the
epitome of love and kindness but what I
love based on this insta her ex Chris
Martin is totally okay with her upcoming
I Do's how do they make this modern
family work luckily I have a deeply
loving ex-husband who's very open minded
and it's for the kids you don't want
your kids to suffer obviously if I could
have you know stayed married to the
father of my kids that's kind of the
dream and but it didn't work out for me
so I'm really lucky that I found a
partner that's patient and loves me and
is willing to you know help me with my
process I like how you smile when you
talk about her you get this real twinkle
in your eyes it'll be a race to the
altar this year also engaged couples
include gameofthrones sophie Turner and
Joe Jonas John Cena and Nikki Bella and
Paris Hilton and actor chris Zylka and
we haven't ever seen it up close
how'd you pick this out it was inspired
by her mother's engagement ring I know
she's very family-oriented and in the
old fashion as for the guest list I feel
like you've been hanging out of the
Kardashians lately we saw you at dinner
with Paris Jackson all my girls will be
invited
well Richard will be invited to the
wedding what about Britney Spears I love
bread everyone yeah
[Music]
[Applause]